this is like a triple omelet but a lot
more ingredients than a normal mesh
first start off with some lovely smoked
bacon slice the bacon bacon in a salt
little tip the pepper
start off on a high heat get that bacon
really nice and crispy otherwise you
just boil the bacon and it's got that
soft unpleasant texture in the potato go
down the gas and now start adding your
veg roughly chop a red pepper and add it
to the pan the peppers on the bacon take
the longest of it's always got to go in
first now sucker them off the peppers
have been cooked now from that sort of
rendered fat the bacon and then your
spring onions just bunch them up slice
them I want them on an angle so they
come like little green diamonds spring
onions in now for the eggs cracking the
eggs that size pan seven or eight eggs
I'll fill it right to the very top I'm
more importantly when I turn this out I
want it like a gateau nice and thick so
slice through an silvers wonderful veg
on a season the eggs with some Parmesan
cheese be quite generous because it adds
a really nice saltiness fresh ground
pepper and then whisk whisk up those
eggs nicely then add peas to the pan and
to give the dish a wonderful aromatic
freshness some fragrant chopped basil
want to chop that sort of roughly
because I want to see those flecks of
green going in weight looking charming
and how many times have you seen Oh a
dull omelet patatas in my mind really
help encapsulate the magic of having
savory eggs cooked beautifully but with
texture now just before we had the ace
I've got this beautiful little ghost
cheese and it's strong and powerful so I
want to slice it into little chunks and
then just have it dot it around I want
to discover these little pockets of
creamy goat cheese now slowly add the
eggs
fill that right up
I need spoon now just let all that egg
go down to the bottom bring it back up
to the boil and sort of clean around the
sides and then some of this delicious
salty creamy ghost cheese over the top
yeah I want it melting like a perfect
slice cheese on toast
nice now from there turn the grill on
for four to five minutes
mmm now just looking at that delicious
take a little paring knife and just make
sure it's released on the sides just
take your panel tab that will hopefully
release the frittata from the bottom of
the pan now bought over the pan turn
that gently just shake sailing prayer
lift off now from there on there is
there look now slice through
mmm
you can see how soft and creamy that is
in the center Matt gostrey's are just
melting almost like a little sauce
inside so exciting but more importantly
it's so easy to do it's got texture it's
got creaminess and that for me will beat
any omelet for brunch serve with a stack
of hot buttered toast and a steaming pot
of coffee this easy patata turns the
humble egg into the perfect dish for
kicking off the weekend whilst the prof
infuses soak your rice noodles in
boiling water for 10 minutes just enough
time to fry your fritters now think
what's going on the tartness the heat
the caramel the color on the ribs is
amazing